Daniel: Greetings.
Bert: All right, well, our next session.
Hey, Bert.
Greetings.
Great.
Hey, how you doing?
Good, good.
Dmitry: Very well.
Daniel: Our next session is with Bert
DeVries, Dmitri Bagaev, and Bart Van Erp.
.
It's going to be called towards User
Friendly Design of Synthetic Active
inference agents.
And I know a lot of people are super
excited to see this really practical and
cutting edge work.
So to you, Bert, and just let us know how
we can support.
Bert: Okay, great.
Is my audio good?
Daniel: Yep, sounds good.
Bert: Okay, then I'm going to share my
screen.
I hope I picked the right one.
I don't work with zoom quite often.
Looks good.
Yeah.
All right.
Super.
Well, thanks a lot, Daniel, for hosting
this symposium.
I've been watching some talks.
It's really amazing.
And we feel privileged to get a chance to
present ourselves.
So we are also, just like a few others
before us, interested in developing a
toolbox for active inference.
And so this picture, or she kind of shows
what we're about or what we are
interested in.
So here's a lady on the left hand side,
and I'm going to try to get a laser
pointer.
And she has this idea about a rewarding
behavior for a vacuum cleaning robot,
right?
So she's writing down she has a textual
expression.
Move around the apartment, apply suction
until the floor is clean, do not touch
objects, and when done, return to the dog.
.
So that's not so hard.
I'm going to rate that with one star out
of three stars in terms of difficulty
level to specify that.
But that's not enough to program this
robot, right?
Because what she really needs to do now
is to specify a generative model and
there's effectors and actuators, right.
The robot has to move around, apply
suction until the floor is clean.
So there are sensors, probably a camera.
Do not touch objects.
Or maybe there has to be object
recognition.
This is a really difficult task to come
up with this generative model here.
And on top of that, she has to specify
this kind of rewarding behavior in terms
now of probability distributions of this
generative model.
So very difficult.
I'm going to rate that with two stars
because the next thing she has to do for
this model is to specify the inference
procedure to do actually active inference
and free energy minimization in real time
for this complex model.
And really that's almost impossible,
right?
Only a few specialists can really write a
procedure for variational free energy
minimization in some very difficult model.
.
So what we are about what we've been
working on is to try to automate the
inference task.
So get rid of the three stars.
And yes, she will still have to specify
her model, but in the long term, we try
to get away from that.
So in the long term, we hope we will get
a toolbox.
And now we're talking 510 years, right,
where a textual description would be
enough to specify some initial model with
an initial prior and everything else is
just automated inference, learning of
states, parameters, structural adaptation
of the model, even maybe based on her
feedback updating the prior.
So that's long term for now, we would be
very happy if we could just automate the
inference task.
So why is it so difficult to specify
inference for an active inference agent?
Well, we have so many competing KPIs,
right?
We want to do this for large model scopes,
, not just for ABCD models, but maybe
there's also continuous variables and
hierarchical models, right?
It must be very user friendly.
We really don't want her to worry about
robustness of her code.
We don't want her to worry about whether
two variables have conjugate
relationships adaptivity.
We want to update states, parameters,
maybe even the model.
The model structure has to be low power
because these ancients often run on edge
devices, so they run on their battery
powered has to be in real time because
you can't learn how to ride a bike if
there's no real time reasoning.
And on top of that, you actually want to
minimize variational frequency, right?
You want to do it at least as good or at
least in a neighborhood of if you would
do a manual derivation.
And some of these decidorata bite each
other, right?
If you want to minimize variational free
energy, but you have to do it in real
time and on low power that kind of bites
each other, right?
So these are difficult KPIs that they're
all important.
You can't just take one out because then
the whole system wouldn't work.
So when you read papers on active
inference, you often also read and now we
implement variation of minimization and
that can be done by message passing on a
graph.
And I want to clarify first why it has to
be done by message passing on the graph.
I do that by giving a very short answer
and then do an example.
The short answer is that Bayesian
inference involves computing very large
sum of products, like what you see here
on the left hand side.
Here's a product AC, ADBC, and then we
sum them AC plus ad and so forth.
This is a sum of products.
Now, we know by the Distributive law that
this here on the left hand side can also
be computed as on the right hand side.
If I multiply this out, I get a times C
plus a times D and so forth.
This is a product of sums and they're
exactly the same thing.
The only difference is that to compute
the left hand side takes four additions
sorry, four multiplications and three
additions.
To compute the right hand side takes two
additions and only one multiplication.
So on the right hand side is much cheaper
to compute than the left hand side.
Normally when we write down
marginalization and Beijing inference, we
write things down as in the left hand
side what message passing does on the
graph, it will automatically convert that
into much cheaper to evaluate product of
sums.
And I'll give an example of that.
So here is an example model F of seven
variables x one, x two through x seven.
And this model happens to be factorized
FA of x one, FB, x two and so forth.
Now, we can draw this factorization as a
graph.
And what we do, and this is called a
Farney style factor graph, what we do is
for each factor FA, we allocate a node.
So FB gets a node and FC gets a node.
And we associate the variables in our
system with the edge.
And an edge is connected to a node if
that variable is an argument of that
function.
So FC is a function of x one, x two, x
three.
And that means that FC connects to the
edges x one, x two, x three, and FD is
only a function of x four.
So FD only connects to the edge x four.
So what you can see in this graph is this
graph is nothing but a visualization of
the factorization assumptions that we
have for this model.
Now, if I'm interested in a big
marginalization task and I integrate out
over all variables but x three, so x one,
x two, x four and so forth through x
seven, I'm interested in this.
Then taking advantage of this
factorization, I can rewrite basically
this sum of product into a product of
sums as below here, what you will see
here below this computes exactly the same
thing.
But I've made use of this distributive
law.
For instance, FC contains no x four, no x
five.
So I moved it over the summation sign to
the left.
And FB also doesn't contain x four, x
five, x six, seven.
So I moved it all the way to the left.
And when you do that, you are left here
with an expression where I only sum over
two variables and here I have to sum over
six variables and here over two, and here
over two.
So you can imagine if each variable, let'
's say x one, x two, if each variable has
ten interesting values that you need to
sum over, then I have here the original
marginalization problem.
I have ten to the power six, so a million
terms, and here in red I have 100 terms
and here I have 100 and here I have 100.
So here I have 300 terms and here I have
1 million terms.
So it's an enormous reduction in
computational complexity when we make use
of this distributive law.
Now, it turns out that if you write this
out, you can associate these intermediate
factors with messages on the graph.
It's just an interpretation, a visual
interpretation.
It's as if FC receives a message from FA
and FB receive or FC receives a message
from FB and computes an outgoing message
MU x three.
And the same thing for Fe.
So Fe receives a message from its
neighboring factors, FD and FF and
computes an outgoing message, x three.
So what you see here is that the entire
marginalization process can be
represented as basically computing a few
messages on a graph and multiplying some
of these messages with each other.
And that's how you can do Bayesian
inference and also how you can do
variational free energy minimization.
So this works in factorized models, but I
would say even stronger if your model is
not factorized and you have a lot of
variables, there is just no way you can
do proper inference.
So any serious model is factorized, like
the brain is almost sparse, is almost
empty.
We have, what is it, about 10 billion
neurons, and each neuron connects to a
few thousand other neurons.
So if I would draw the graph, that graph
is almost empty, it is hugely sparse.
And so there is no other way to do
inference in the brain than by message
passing.
So that's why message passing, just
because it's more effective than anything
else.
Now then the issue is which message do
you compute?
How do you compute messages?
Because there are different ways of doing
it right.
And we also read in active inference
papers, you can do this by variational
message passing, or expectation
maximization, or belief propagation and
variational LaPlace and all these terms.
It turns out that there is an umbrella
framework for all these methods passing
frameworks.
And that umbrella framework is called
Constraint better free energy
minimization.
And I will try to illustrate it by this
slide.
So here I have this graph.
This is just an example graph where my
generative model is basically factorized
in FA, FB, FC, FD and Fe.
And I've also written that here.
So this now is the variational free
energy.
Now, I haven't made any assumption on Q
of X.
So Q of X is still Q of x one, x two, x
three.
It's just a joint overall variables and
it doesn't have any factorization
assumption.
It makes sense to also assume that the
posterior kind of follows the
factorization assumption of the prior,
namely of the generative model.
So if we make that assumption and that
means we're going to make the assumption
that QX is also now a product of QAS of X
of A, where QAS of X of A stands for
beliefs over nodes.
What I mean by that is that Q of B is a
posterior belief over this node, meaning
it's a posterior belief over the edges
that connect to this node.
Just like FB is a function of x one, x
two, x four, that's if you will, the
prior or the generative model, then Q of
B, the variational posterior for this
node will also depend on x one, x two, x
four, and on no other factors.
If you just do that, then you will count
some of the variables double because x
one is part of the belief over FA, but
also part of the belief over FB.
So we just have to discount that by
dividing by beliefs over edges.
That means that I make now an assumption
that my posterior beliefs is divided into
local beliefs over notes and local
beliefs over edges over variables.
This will make things a lot simpler.
In fact, if my graph is a tree and I did
the tree here, and I would do message
passing on that tree and I could suppose
I could do that perfectly, everything is
linear gaussian, then I get perfect
Bayesian inference.
There is no approximation.
So this is a good assumption.
Sometimes it's still very hard to compute
a message because even the single
messages that come out of these nodes,
they're still integrals or summations,
and in particular the integrals may be a
problem.
We may not have an analytical answer.
So what we sometimes do is add additional
assumptions.
We'll say, well, the posterior belief
over FD, I can't compute it in general,
but I'm going to just assume now that it'
's a gaussian that makes it easier.
Or we can make an extra factorization
assumption and say the posterior belief
over FB, which is really a belief over
the joint x one, x two, x four is going
to be broken into independent belief over
x one and belief over x two and x four.
These additional assumptions, if I impose
them as well, this is what I recall.
Now, if I all substituted here in Q of x,
I get what's called a constrained beth
free energy.
This is the same Beth as in the
Oppenheimer movie.
This is Hans Bethe, where it's named
after.
We have a graph now that is highly
factorized and we have local beliefs over
notes and over and they're indicated with
red and we have additional constraints in
green.
They could be Gaussians or mean field
constraints or other constraints.
And now we will assume constraints that
make it possible to compute all the
messages.
And now we can just automate this by
making different assumptions.
We can turn this into expectation
maximization or belief propagation or
hybrid forms thereof.
We can turn it into any relevant message
passing algorithm that you've heard of.
So this is a very nice umbrella framework
that basically encompasses everything.
We've written a pretty large paper on
this in the Entropy Journal where you can
read all the math on how this works.
So we've talked about why message passing,
, namely because it's the most effective
way of doing inference.
And we've talked about which messages to
compute, namely we turn our variational
free energy into something called a
constraint, better free energy and then
we can compute messages.
The only thing that's left is, well, when
do we pass these messages?
What is the sequence of messages?
Which one comes first?
And this is where we see a lot of papers,
right?
You have to write control flow, what's
called control flow.
You have to say, okay, here is my
algorithm for active inference.
First I specify a model.
Then let's do inference for every time
step, collect a new observation, update
the state, update the desired future, and
so forth, compute expected free energy,
select the policy, et cetera.
This kind of program.
The problem with active inferences is
that there is nested for loops in here.
Here's a for loop, and here's another for
loop.
And for each of these policies, I'm going
to have to go into the future, so I'm
going to have another time loop.
So it is for loops, in for loops, in for
loops.
This will completely explode in terms of
computational complexity.
So as a result, some very clever people
have written very clever algorithms of
doing this much faster.
Sophisticated inference, branching time
active inference, dynamic programming EFE
are recent proposals for doing this very
clever.
In the end, all of these proposals come
down to a particular just a message
passing schedule.
Once we commit to message passing on the
graph as our inference procedure, it's
the only thing that's going on.
And all of this sophisticated inference
and branching time active inference, all
it does is it schedules the messages.
It says first this message, then this
message, then this message.
I don't mean that as a slight to these
algorithms.
They're very clever.
And as we've seen in the presentation by
Aswin Paul, you get huge improvements if
you go from regular inference to
sophisticated inference.
But it's good to realize that these
algorithms just specify in a graph which
message comes after which message.
So here's an example of a graph and a
message sequence.
Here's message one, then message two, and
message three goes up, and then we go
from FC to FF, and here's message five,
and then we go to Fe.
And this could correspond this sequence
to dynamic time programming EFE or
sophisticated inference.
There are a couple of problems with this
approach, which basically with having the
user to specify a clever algorithm, first
of all, you have to be a specialist to do
it right.
Only these are very clever people.
That means that if we let it leave it to
say to an engineer in a company, well, it'
's a high probability he's not going to
get it right.
That's very unfortunate.
But there is another issue, and that is
that in a sense, it's a global variable
in the message passing schedule.
All nodes are visited, because if a node
would not be visited, then we shouldn't
have it in the graph.
And that means if one node crashes,
basically the message passing schedule is
invalid.
I have to reset my system.
And if you fly a drone, if it's deployed
and it's out in the field and a node
crashes, a transistor burns out, and I
have to totally reset now my system, I
have to compute a new message passing
schedule.
Then you're not doing inference and your
drone flies into the wall.
So this is not robust.
And it also for the same reason we may
actually want to take out a node.
We may want to prune a node, we want to
do structural adaptation.
And we can't do structural adaptation
because we have to reset the system,
recompute a message passing schedule.
So this procedural style where an
engineer specifies which message comes
after this message has some disadvantages.
.
It's not very robust.
And if you want to do it very clever, you
have to be really a specialist.
So a better system is what we call
reactive message passing.
And it's very related to what was in the
first session called the actor model.
Keith Duggar had a nice presentation on
the actor model.
So what we will do is we will say we will
not have a global message passing
schedule.
The engineer will not specify anything
anymore.
The inference code that an engineer will
have to write is just say, react to any
free energy minimization opportunity.
In other words, there is no inference
code.
It's completely automated.
And we will replace this global message
passing schedule by local triggering
inside the node.
So each node is now just an autonomous
system that's interested in minimizing
its free energy.
It can do so by sending out messages.
And when will it do so?
Well, it receives messages, and then when
it looks at these messages and it feels
like, oh, there is an opportunity for me
to minimize free energy by or expected
free energy energy by sending out a
message.
Then we'll send out a message and each
node will do so by itself asynchronously
so you get parallel distributed
processing, or concurrent processing, as
Keith called it.
In principle, you could play this game on
many computers at the same time, and so
you get tremendous advantages.
First of all, you don't have to write
difficult code.
Second of all, you can do multithreading
or you can run it on multiple computers
at the same time.
And there's also robustness advantages
because if a node crashes, then there's
nothing that stops the system from just
finding another path, right?
If this node crashes, this path from here'
's message three, this path now doesn't
work.
So I cannot send anything to Fe anymore
from X.
Well, then I just sent a new message here.
.
Why not?
It's like when water falls down a
mountain and it zigzags its way down into
the value and you halfway put up an
obstruction.
It just finds another path, not the
preferred path.
This has to find, well, the second best
path, because the first path has been
obstructed, right?
And that's what's going to happen in this
system as well, right?
That's just how nature works.
It tries to find the best path, the
easiest path, and if that's not available,
, then we do the second best path.
And that's also what you can do with
reactive message passing.
So you can prune nodes.
You can do structural adaptation, and it'
's far more robust.
And you can also do chance encounters
with other drones, right?
Drones that get close can start
communicating with each other, and when
they fire away, they stop communicating
with each other.
And this is no problem, because you can
basically change who change nodes can
change on the fly, who they communicate
to and who they want to listen to.
That's the way nature works, and also how
it works when we do reactive programming
and reactive message passing.
So, in summary, we're interested in
automating inference, in active inference
agents, right?
Because it's an operation that's
basically only for experts.
And this active inference technology is
not going to be successful unless we get
more people, let's say, democracies it,
and we get competent engineers being able
to develop good agents, right?
You shouldn't have to be a top specialist
in the world to develop an active
inference agent.
Now, in order to automate inference, you
must do message passing, and I've talked
about that for efficiency.
I've also talked about which messages to
pass.
Not necessarily do you have to follow
this framework, but constrained better
Free energy framework is very convenient.
.
It's an umbrella framework that basically
goes over all the interesting other
message passing computations.
When message passing, reactive message
passing, it's fully automated, so you don'
't have to write any code anymore.
In principle, you can do parallel
distributed processing.
It's robust structural changes.
You can learn new inference pathways.
So lots of advantages here.
Now, how do we do it?
I like to introduce a toolbox that we've
been working on called ARX infer.
And we do that with my lab here at the
university.
I'm here in Eindhoven in the south of the
Netherlands, and we have a lab.
The lab is called BIS lab.
Here are postdocs and assistant
professors and PhD students, and we've
been working on this for many years.
And some of these, like Albert and Ismail
and Tyce, have written dissertations.
And our best work, we have consolidated
that in a toolbox.
And the toolbox is called Arcs infer.
And if you want to have a look, you can
go to the website, arcsinfer.
ML.
And Arctinfur works in the way that I've
just discussed.
It does message passing.
It tries to minimize constraint, better
free energy.
That means it can come up with all kinds
of message passing algorithms.
It will do it in a reactive way, and it
will try to do it in real time and low
power and all the KPIs that we're talking
about.
Now, it's, of course, not done, but it's
functional and like to show some demos.
And I will leave it to Dimitri and Bart,
who are two advanced PhD students in my
lab to show the demos.
So I'm going to stop sharing.
Daniel: Awesome.
Thank you, Bert.
Great talk.
Bert: Sure.
Dmitry: Can you hear?
Bert: Yeah.
Yeah.
Dmitry: Okay.
I will try to share my screen.
Bert: Okay.
Dmitry: So you should see it now.
Daniel: Looks good.
Dmitry: Okay, so, yeah, hello to everyone,
, I'm Dmitry
Bagaev. So I'm a PhD student in Bioslab
in Einhoven University of Technology, and
yes, I have a small presentation about
actual software developments in so over
the past few years, we have significantly
improved our tools.
And basically my entire PhD was dedicated
to implement this idea, which Beard was
talking about, like implementing the
variation of reactive message passing.
And in this presentation, I just want to
show you what you can actually do using
this theory under the hood.
Okay, so basically, in order to automate
active inference, we need to automate
Bayesian inference.
And we have already a lot of solutions
for that, such as Pyro NumPy, which is
funded by Google, Info.
Net is funded by Microsoft, turing is in
July, PIMC, and many, many.
And basically these solutions are really
good and they're really good at
prototyping as well.
But our goal is eventually to be able to
deploy these kind of systems, not just
prototype.
And we are really focusing on these
particular properties for this automated
Bayesian inference.
So it must be low power, adaptive, real
time scalable.
It also must be user friendly at the end
and must support a large scope of models
if we want it to be useful.
In Bioslab, we want to build such a
software with such nice properties and it'
's always about trade offs, right?
So we do something better in one
particular domain and maybe other
software libraries, they might be better
in a different domain, but we are really
focusing on this particular property.
And so, yes, I will reiterate a little
bit Bert's presentation.
So how do we achieve this?
So imagine we have an environment and we
have an agent, and the agent takes some
actions and the agent basically what he
needs is to come up with some sort of
good enough probabilistic model of its
environment in order to do patient
inference.
And in our framework, we encode the model
as a factor graph, which not only models
the observations, but also actions and
desired future.
And this approach allows us to decompose
these complex relationships between
variables and hidden states into some
kind of structure and local blocks.
And it's not a black box anymore.
And the model itself may have some sort
of background motivation interpretation.
It may encode your prior knowledge about
some particular physical system and the
locality of these blocks basically allows
you to scale to millions of variables and
hidden states.
It allows you to pre optimize it maybe,
or maybe use some sort of different
approximation strategies in different
places.
So it allows a lot of very nice
properties as well.
And we use reactive message passing to
run actual variational Bayesian inference.
.
It uses reactive programming under the
hood to minimize the approximation to the
variational free energy.
And yes, as Bert also mentioned, it's
very much related to actor model.
And basically in Ariks and fur.
You can think of different nodes as
actors themselves and they have basically
one single purpose is to send a
variational message that minimizes free
energy.
This is a very short and very high level
description, but it is essentially what
is happening under lipid.
So we are not treating different agents
which interact with each other as actors,
but we also treat the actual components
of the underlying model as actors
themselves.
It's like a very hierarchical structure.
So this is the main central idea of this
inference.
So here for example, first example, we
can do an inference in a dynamical system.
.
This example, which is quite old already,
I think it's like two years ago.
So we track a position of the object
given some noisy measurements which are
indicated by green dots, the actual real
signal, we cannot observe it, but we just
can plot.
It is shown as blue and the inferred
signal is shown as red and the data set
is infinite.
The inference end just reacts on it and
does not assume any particular data size.
.
Simply reacts in your observation as soon
as possible.
Yeah, I'm actually not sure how smoothly
Zoom shares my screen.
Maybe you can see it's a bit lagging in
the animations, I'm not sure because
maybe zoom does not share it on a full
frame rate.
And also on the right hand side you can
see how we define models in our framework.
.
We use Julia as a programming language.
Basically, this is everything that you
need to define this particular model and
run inference on a data set.
And actually I literally spent more days
to plot it instead of inference.
So inference was an easiest part for me,
plotting was way much harder to relate to
user friendliness.
And we actually have plans to improve our
model specification language, make it
even easier.
So now for technical reasons, we have
some auxiliary statements in the model
specification language, but we are
working to improve that and make it even
easier.
This is another example which is similar
to the previous one, that uses much more
complex and linear dynamical system of
the double pendulum.
And the system is chaotic and we can
observe only a small part of it with a
lot of noise, also indicated as a green
dots.
And nevertheless, given good enough model,
, you can infer the other hidden states
with pretty much high precision and the
code needed for that is also relatively
short.
We also have examples with active
inference agents that interact with their
environment.
So the left up shows mountain car problem,
, very famous problem.
The left bottom side shows an active
inference agent which tries to control
the inverted pendulum from falling in the
windy conditions it reacts in wind.
We also have a demo of an agent that
controls a pendulum in an ever changing
environment.
So on the right side you see a pendulum
with an engine and engine has limited
power and.
The agent itself needs to reach the goal
and the goal is indicated as a red circle.
.
Basically, in this demo we can change the
environment in real time and see how the
agent reacts.
So we can change the mass of the pebble
among its length or the amount of noise
in the measurements, or we can change the
goal, we can change maximum engine power,
et cetera.
So the agent will still try to infer the
best possible course of actions in order
to reach its goal and it just never stops
reacting.
It's also actually possible to restrict
engine power such that it will not longer
possible to reach the goal, right?
But the agent will still try.
We have other cool demos with smart
navigation and collision avoidance which
are still under active research and the
code for them is not available publicly
it will be soon available, but for
example in this example we can define a
set of agents with their boundaries and a
set of their destinations.
And we can see how they try to resolve
their routes altogether.
And we can have some static obstacles in
the map.
We can see how agents can find their most
optimal path in order to reach their
goals and avoid any possible collision.
And it's also not necessary to have
static obstacles, the obstacles
themselves may move.
So on this demo we have hundreds of
agents that navigate through a map of
obstacles that move from bottom to top to
the circles or obstacles.
And agents are depicted as small dots and
they need to go from left to right,
basically avoid any sort of collision.
And as I also mentioned, we want to
perform efficient and real time inference,
, but we also to do it like low power,
low performance on low performance
devices such as Raspberry, Pi or Coolpy
as an example.
And we have some results of successfully
running the Bayesian audio source
separation, for example, on coolpy.
So it is actually possible we try to run
active inference agents also on Coolpy.
So as the aforementioned inverted
pendulum, and as I mentioned, we also
need to have a large model scope and
basically RICS infer has not been
designed to solve any of the
aforementioned problems.
Specifically, we have a large set of
different examples in our repository,
different models, different data,
different inference constraints.
We have examples for linear regression,
hidden Markov model altogether, grace
model hierarchy models, misheard models,
Gaussian process and so, right?
So this approach is very versatile.
And for example, if you compare it with
sort of a conventional software libraries
where you let's say have a library that
solves a common filter, might be a very
great library, maybe super fast, have top
performance works great and very reliable,
, super good.
But then you are constrained by this
particular model common filtering,
right?
And you can't really change it much.
In Ericsson Fur we are free to define our
own models which we can pretty much
easily define a model that essentially
would act equivalently to common
filtering equation.
And so basically in the demo that I
showed before about object tracking, it
was essentially a common filter but was
written in a probabilistic model.
So yeah, that was my small addition to
Bear's presentation.
So our software is free MIT license and
it's open source available on GitHub.
Yeah, and we would be happy thanks to be
able to present where we would be happy
to answer.
Any, thanks.
Daniel: Awesome.
All right, I'll just ask a quick question.
.
In the chat Marco asks sorry if I missed
it are the collision avoidance demos real
time adapting to other agents behavior or
is it a collectively pre computed path?
Dmitry: So basically they are not super
real time, they're kind of fast to
compute this path, like maybe 5 seconds
or so.
But we are basically working to make it
real time.
So we know what is the problem, we know
where to improve and we will make it real
time.
Yes, almost.
Daniel: Next question.
Do you have some comparative data with
other methods?
And just more generally, what kinds of
benchmarks or when you're talking with
industry in different settings, what are
people looking for that killer app of
active inference?
Or what are they looking for their key
measures?
Dmitry: So I personally have a big paper
about comparison with sampling based
methods like HMC and also in my PhD
thesis, there will be a comparison with
nuts, also other sampling based methods.
So, long story short, sampling based
methods cannot really run this kind of
sophisticated inference in real time.
They're very time consuming.
They do not really scale well to large
problems which is really needed for
active inference agents.
Because if you have a large environment,
very complicated, you will have a lot of
unknown variables in your model.
There is a paper that compares and
basically we show that our approach
scales much, much better.
So I personally run on just a regular
MacBook laptop, I run the model with 2
million unknown variables and it was
quite fast.
With sampling based methods you may find
yourself in a model with like 100
variables and then you wait like 2 hours
or something and then it turns out that
your chain did not converge or something
like that.
Daniel: Cool.
Yeah, it's people commenting in the chat
like how far message passing and factor
graphs have come.
And so to Bias Lab and to Bert at all, we
definitely appreciate this exciting line
of research.
I mean, there's so much to learn there
and sometimes looking at the equations,
it can seem like it's like written in
stone and just sort of the beginning and
the end is, you know, variational free
energy.
But then in your presentations you're
really showing like no, we are hands on.
That's where we get the interpretability,
the modularity, that's where it really is
implemented.
And it's like an information logistics
challenge.
It's not like an esoteric philosophy
question at that point.
Bert: No, indeed.
I should say it's taken us we are no
geniuses, right.
So our lab exists more than eight years,
and you see all the people in the lab, it'
's taken us many years with lots of wrong
directions to get this to work to where
it's now.
So it's a very long path.
But at this moment, I'm pretty confident
that at some point in the future and we
don't want to say in three months or in
one year, but we will be able to write a
toolbox that will allow people to design
a generative model and just press a
button and forget about the inference.
You don't have to worry about inference
anymore.
It will be fast and automated, and that
will happen, and it will happen within a
few years.
And maybe somebody else will write an
even better toolbox.
But I'm pretty confident that even our
toolbox will be able to do that.
People talk about, why don't we have the
success of deep learning and generative
AI, right?
Well, they have the success because of
big data availability of big data, big
computers and toolboxes TensorFlow and
all the successes.
We don't need big data because agents
collect their own data in the field.
We don't need big computers, active
influence agents, they manage their power
resources.
But we need a really good toolbox because
programming an active inference agent,
programming the inference by hand is just
not doable.
So we need a really good toolbox that
really automates this.
We hope Arcs Infer will be one of the
first toolboxes to do that.
I am sure that other people will also be
working on it, and better toolboxes will
come about.
But I think the optimistic message is
that it will happen.
And once we have a toolbox like that,
then we can actually a large community
can start building agents, and we can
actually show deployable agents in the
field that they work.
And they work better than reinforcement
learning agent or whatever is out there.
Right.
So I think that's a very positive and
hopeful message.
Daniel: It's what we expect.
It's what we prefer.
Bert: Yeah.
Daniel: Any last comments from either of
you?
Bert: Comments from us?
No, I'm just very happy to get the
opportunity, and yeah, I want to
everybody can download this toolbox.
I think at this moment, you still should
be a programmer to work with the toolbox.
.
And I hope you're friendly, because it's
not totally polished in the way that we
want.
But it's coming, right?
It's coming.
In the next years, there will be a good
toolbox for almost everybody to use, but
people that are interested, even people
that are interested to work.
Here at Biaslab, we have an open position
for PhD students, so we're happy to
receive emails from people that are
interested to work with us.
Dmitry: Thank you.
Daniel: Dimitri, anything in closing?
Dmitry: No, just that.
Thank you again for possibility to
present.
Super nice to be here.
Daniel: Cool.
Dmitry: Yeah.
Daniel: Well, later in the year, we will
be discussing your two part recent work,
and so we're going to be getting a lot
into the details, and I hope that people
in the institute and the ecosystem will
be as excited as we all are.
Thank you.
Bert: Thank you.
Bye.